I'm saying why not it let's just abolish
the police let's just see what happens
if it crashes and burns okay then it
crashes burn that's how black lives
matter if it crashes and burns but many
black people be killed innocent black
[Music]
people time for the newest installment
of change my mind where we rationalize
our positions on controversial topics
for this installment we set up shop in
Austin Texas to discuss why antifa
should be labeled a domestic terrorist
[Music]
organization leave the area to the
now we're going to burn your building
[Music]
down but we realized antifa is a little
niche so we wanted to cast our net wider
so one and the same black lives matter
is a domestic terrorist organization
peaceful protests across the country
were upended by violence over the
weekend this is the mostly a protest uh
it is not uh it is not generally
speaking unruly but fires have been
started so there is some of that but for
the most part they have been very very
peaceful when we do when we move with
the Panthers trust me when you see me
move I'm moving in
violence if they go about they burden of
whatever they said you're doing you pull
your piss out you bu was that a
church potluck I couldn't tell the
difference but what do you think do you
think that black lives matter the
organization should be considered a
domestic terrorist group let me know in
the comments below but let's get on with
the show first up Alana all right so
your name is Alena alen can you spell
that for me e l e n a okay and you know
you know that this is being filmed
obviously you can tell by the giant
camera I should use my fake name or well
that's fine uh I have a bunch of fake
names but I don't know why I do it it
just makes me feel more secure you know
like I'm undercover doing something
something important um so like I said we
kind of just talked about it the idea is
to rationalize our positions on
controversial topics and hopefully it
doesn't emerge into a shouting match
that's why we try and sit down we can't
offer you any beverage right now because
the co the whole the virus and the bird
flu um but yeah I do believe
unequivocally that black lives matter
the organization as it stands uh right
now and and yeah the way the movement is
developed but specifically the
organization is a domestic terrorist
organization is it because of the recent
damage it's because of a lot of things
yeah so I mean you're over uh $600
million in property damage right 18
officers or 18 people killed over 20
people killed sort of in an auxiliary
fashion around these uh protests 14,000
arrests and all of this is being carried
out specifically uh to try and uh
obviously get their demands met which
are outlined by their Charter and their
Founders and you know I think that might
be something that a lot of people may
not be familiar with so I have them
right here this is from the black lives
matter organization uh you can grab one
of those if you want
so you asked an interesting question I
don't have a problem with the idea that
black lives matter I don't think anyone
has a problem with that just like if you
say hey this is the don't kick puppies
movement nobody has a problem with it
but when you look at the reason they're
carrying out these acts of violence
right now
across the country as you well know here
in Austin I mean the city is just I'm
amazed as to how terrible it is here
it's nothing but wooden boards and
homeless people um that's sure I saw
them when I was walking yeah it's really
pretty are you from Austin uh no I'm not
from Austin so you're visiting
yes you picked a hell of a time to
visit it's usually better than this um
so with all that yeah I believe they're
a terrorist organization a domestic
terrorist
organization and what do you if you
disagree with that you're more than
welcome to change my mind well I guess I
disagree because I feel like you know
you can't just group everyone into you
know like of course there's obviously
people who are doing bad stuff you know
like you know stealing from people who
like their small businesses and
everything you know and I understand
that right but I feel like
Mur I guess yeah guess I think that's a
big problem the murdering The Killing I
did see one video where one person was
being assaulted oh no no no no we have
the numbers yeah right here I mean it's
over it's over 18 dead 900 officer
casualties as well um yeah there have
been been a lot of deaths I mean this
guy actually are you aware of who this
is uh is it um who was that
African-American officer yeah David
Dorne yes yeah he was killed too so yes
I heard about that that was really sad
yeah it was really mhm yeah he was the
older gentleman I felt I that was
problematic yeah was it the it was the
like looters and the riers being carried
out from the looters and the riters yeah
in the name of uh of George Floyd and
black lives matter so what about the
people who are like innocent what about
you know like the people who are like
you know they have a problem with like
police brutality and then people who
have a problem with you know black
people you know being you know murdered
and hurt in the country I have a problem
with that yeah I have a problem with
that um so I want to kind of unpack that
but before we get to that like I said my
problem is really with the organization
I think when you see what the
organization black lives matter which by
the way is a very influential very
well-funded organization what their
demands are um then maybe you see where
you have a problem with it so we can go
through these together do you agree with
these demands um the dismantling of
cisgender privilege uplifting black
Trans people disrupting the Western
prescribed nuclear family structure
completely abolishing the
police I do have a problem I guess with
the family structure cuz I think um like
you know it's very low the percentage of
like people who grow up with fathers in
like the community in the black
community yes so I do feel like that's
very problematic especially I grew up in
a culture where that's just not that
doesn't happen you just don't not have a
dad you know so you did have a dad yes I
did have a dad that's good yeah I
consider that a m when we talk about
privilege you know I don't like to see
things through just the prism of race
but having a family having a father and
mother is is a tremendous privilege I
think it's very important I think also
too like I think that's I feel like
that's something that can be very
beneficial to have our fathers in the
house you know so I do not I guess I
guess I don't agree with the like not
having a family structure cuz I think
that's important yeah yes so these are
the demands from black lives matter the
founders and you can actually go read
them on their website you know we have
some links there so considering that
these are the demands and obviously the
rioting and the Looting which is I mean
un unprecedented levels of violence and
property damage um at what point what
what would be required I guess if you
don't consider that domestic terrorism
you know $600 million in property damage
around 20 something people killed 900
officer casualties these are the demands
of the
organization what would be required for
you to see it as domestic terrorism at a
certain
point that's a good question I'm not
sure I feel like I just I feel like the
term domestic terrorism I feel like it's
very hard it is to to pinpoint you know
like even then like people are you know
say that KKK they're also a domestic
terrorist organization sure yeah they
could be but it's an or domestic so
domestic let's get rid of that but the
idea of a terrorist organization or
terrorism is to instill Terror fear
using violence or intimidation in order
to achieve right a political or
ideological agenda M so you see that
with things like Isis the Taliban uh you
see it with you could see the KKK for
example and yeah I would say that black
lives matter given their demands and the
levels of violence right now along with
antifa the two have sort of become one
and the same should qualify as a
domestic Terror organization not saying
the words black lives matter not wanting
to talk about black issues because
everyone agrees with that but isn't that
a problem them was the leadership that
they're not telling people to cuz I
remember when I was seeing the writing
and looting on TV I had a problem
because if you're to say like this I
feel like that's why we're having this
conversation right now right because if
the leadership were to say like hey you
know the people who are doing negative
stuff you need to stop right so the
peaceful protesters can continue to do
what they're doing then we wouldn't be
having this conversation of oh are they
a domestic terrorist group or not you
know so the problem is the leadership
does the opposite you know they
reiterate no we want the complete
abolition of all police right one of the
founders wrote reiterated that not in
the New York Times M so we're not
talking about Fringe people you know
randomly on Third Street we're talking
about founding members of the black
lives matter movement you know it's
pretty hard to say hey go out and
protest peacefully when you're demanding
the complete and total abolition of all
police so this is what they they are
aiming for the organization black lives
matter and I think that a lot of people
who say the words and think that the
words sound good and I would say the
word sound good I think all lives matter
I think black lives matter I think
anytime you say ex lives matter people
are on board with it because there are a
lot of people who are inherently good I
don't really think they know what the
root is of this organization and the
root of the violence and um I think that
it needs to be treated just like any
other Terror organization like the KKK
to use your comparison I think that's an
apt one I think it's actually a good
comparison for you I think um also too I
feel like why maybe a lot of people
don't maybe I guess don't see the damage
is because at least like it happens in a
lot of downtown areas that's why I
noticed too like so for examp but we had
um from in my city we had also like the
like um some like people who were
breaking into stuff right but because
you know you know Texas is a very big
state right so like it's very easy to
just live in your little suburb
community and just post like Oh Black
lives matter but not realize you're not
downtown like nobody I don't know
anybody who lives like downtown Austin
you know right I don't know anybody who
lives like down town like like yeah Del
Rio you know so it's very like well that
brings us to another point is yeah who
who do you think that abolishing the
police right and these acts of violence
that are mostly being carried out in
urban areas who does it affect most
negatively often I guess black people
people of color yeah it's very easy to
say like I remember I was watching this
one video um it was this uh man and he
put his life savings into a uh a
business and um and basically they came
and they ruined it right and it was very
hard to see that right and I'll see like
a lot of people online saying you know
all L of it's Justified even though I
was very hard to agree with because you
know for somebody who lives in a suburb
or who's rich and they're posting you
know oh you know things are replaceable
no that's not always true if you put
your life savings into something and
then somebody comes and destroys it
that's not that's what this man died
helping protect you know he was off duty
at that point officer David Dorne a
black man who served his community which
was this thing keeps coming down because
of my beard so it's okay goes below my
nose um now it's going in my mouth I
don't know how you live with
this I hate all of you I need a better
mask um he was actually it was a friend
who called him and he was off duty and
they were looting his store and he got
shot over a TV from a black lives matter
rioter looter protester and so it's
interesting you know we see a shrine
here for uh Garrett Foster the guy who
was shot in Austin who aimed an AK into
a AK-47 into a car and was shot but how
much do we hear about an officer David
Dorne you if we're talking about black
lives matter this is a black man who
served his community for a very long
time as a police officer who had a
stellar record who went in to protect a
business of his friend that like you
said was his life savings had been pourn
into that and he was shot for a
television set he doesn't get really
honored on television it doesn't really
get covered it's kind of sad that he
just get shot for a television isn't it
sad that's to me it was really even
watching that tape and I was of course
appall as anyone was at the George Floyd
tape um but this was this was really
really tough to take because there was
no misunderstanding there was no
escalation it was just a iy wanted a TV
shot him dead in the street for nothing
um but I would like to go back to
something that you brought up because I
think you made some good point I think
your comparison to the KKK with this
sort of Charter I think is a good one
and I know that you mentioned how
important it was um family and how
important that was in your development
so I mean I'm sure that you're aware of
of the violent crime in the black
community in the United States it's it's
very very high um and unlike actual
racists like the KKK or I would consider
black lives a matter who attribute all
these statistics to race right white
supremacists would say well they commit
murder at 37 times the rate of white
Americans or the average population
because they're black Nick Cannon on the
flip side said white black people have
sold because of the melanin I don't
believe it's that at all I think a huge
start contrast and a reason reason you
see this reflection of Statistics is
like you said because of no fathers in
the home because of having broken
families and so when you look at this
black lives matter the organization and
they demand the complete abolition of
police and they also also want to
disrupt the Western nuclear family I
mean that's it is proactively going to
victimize more black Americans I don't
know but I don't see an organization and
you can correct me this could be the
white privilege talking mm but uh I
don't see this being representative of
what most black Americans
want I
guess what would you like to see come of
all this I would like to see
um I like to see black people have
better lives that's what I would like to
see MH and um and I think it's I think
it's important for black people to have
better lives too I think um what do I
think that's hard I would like to see
black people have better lives too I
would that's what I would like to see
too I'd like to see all Americans and I
hope that the
movement does help them have better
lives that's what I hope I hope some I
hope something helps them have a better
Liv I think the movement is going to
unfortunately I think it's organization
black lives matter and I think the
movement is actually going to set black
Americans back quite a bit and I think
it's going to create more racism let me
ask you this this is a a concern that I
have um you're younger than I am I
believe uh let's say you're a young
white American right now okay I was
raised in sort of a most racial America
I had black friends I was raised in
Canada but was born in Detroit but I had
black friends we had Asian friends it
never really came up right we were the
generation where they wanted everyone to
be the same and now they're demanding
segregated hospitals as you see from
black Liv matter they're demanding
segregated schools they're demanding
black only spaces we would have been
very surprised in my generation yeah
this is happening at universities all
across the country yeah black only
spaces black only study groups they want
segregated schools hospitals right now
testing what do you mean like just to
have like a space where like kind of
like oh you know how there's like
African-American clubs like do you mean
that or do you mean no I mean they want
separate areas of hospitals and
sometimes separate schools they would
like if you look at black lives matter
they are demanding segregation now
though with we have like that problem
with we have inner city schools that are
like you know 90% africanamerican right
but they mean by Design to actually
exclude as a matter of policy people who
are not people of color but I I don't
want to get lost on that point the point
is when I was growing up this was never
something that was being pushed for we
were pushing for Unity pushing to kind
of all be able to be the same um but if
you're a young white American right now
and you see $600 million in property
damage and you go why is that happening
black lives matter and you see 18 plus
people killed and you go why that
happening they go black lives matter and
you see uh an incredibly High violent
crime rate you're seeing it here in
Austin you're seeing in New York and you
go why is that happening they go black
lives matter and you're seeing the idea
of complete abolition of the police and
you have a lot of friends who are
firefighters and you know the police in
your neighborhood you're going why is
that happening they go black lives
matter I'm worried that at a certain
point you're going to get young white
Americans now as opposed to don't like
who go oh so all of this crap that I
don't think is representative of anyone
from our point of view they're going to
go oh that's what black people it create
racism I feel like if anything I
remember when I was looking at Min like
Minnesota what was going on there a lot
of the damage wasn't caused by actual
black people I saw a lot of no offense
I'm not offended like people who were I
hate white hipsters uh too I just I hate
anyone who Dam I don't hate anyone but I
hate the action of damaging anyone
else's property or violating someone
else's rights no matter who does it oh
somebody's taking a picture I don't know
why sorry that's okay uh sorry I'm just
going to cover my face until he's done
is that okay how you doing
man I don't know who he is sorry um
she's just a little uncomfortable with
the picture so yeah okay thanks sorry um
I I no that there was a lot of
um sorry again white people who were
he's a little bit of a weird dude he got
the HGH gut going on yes um I notic
there's a lot of white people who are
the ones doing the damage at least in in
Minnesota some areas yeah and um I found
that very um not problematic but um you
know especially if you're going to say
what you're doing is for black people
and you're doing something that they
might not agree with like I remember the
joy FL family they said they did not
approve of the Looting and the rioting
on TV right and so here's a a black
person who's saying hey I find this very
problematic and then you have people who
are not even the race or the group that
you're fighting for and you now it's
associated with us you see what I'm
trying to say yeah that being said a
majority of the the a lot of this crime
being carried out across the city is is
black lives matter activist and there
are a lot of black people and white
people so I I wouldn't say it's
exclusively white people but it is being
inspired by the movement and the
leadership of black lives matter in
antifa and that's where I have a problem
I I have a problem with a white person
burning down a Walgreens just as much as
I have a problem with someone shooting a
police actually have more of a problem
with someone shooting an off duty police
officer obviously because they're
deliberately harming someone but I have
just as much of a problem with someone
blocking a police car and protest in the
road as I do somebody setting a fire
truck a blaze you know a lot of people
don't realize this when you block a
police car you blocked the fire
department that's true and that happened
that happened in uh I believe it was
Minneapolis that's there was a woman and
her child in a house and what happened
the black lives matter activists blocked
the police car that was trying to PVE
the way for the firetruck well what do
you think do you think that breeds more
peace and you think that breeds more
Unity or you think let's say you're a
white guy in your house or you could be
a black guy but let's say it's a white
person in their house and their wife and
daughter is stuck in there and you can
see the fire department off in the
distance but you know that they can't
get to saving your wife and daughter in
the house because black lives matter
activists and antifa who hate the cops
are blocking the
cops what is that that do that forces
that man to be violent to defend his
family none of this is helpful right
this isn't a peaceful Pro I mean you
look at Austin this doesn't look like if
you walk down Sixth Street this is not
the result of a peaceful protest here in
this
town um and it makes me sad it really
does make me sad here's what I would say
more people sorry I just notic there's a
lot of people there are a lot of people
there are a lot more people if you're
uncomfortable you don't have to stick
around I understand yeah sorry um yeah
but um yes so I I guess I'm not fully
like I understand like I understand your
points I appreciate you for um stating
your opinion and everything um I guess
this is so hard for me to accept the the
statements yeah so could I ask you a
favor small favor because you made some
really good points here I would just the
only thing I would ask and I always ask
people when they when they are able to
sit down reasonably and have uh I think
this has been a pretty respectful
discussion across the board the first
thing you said when you sat down was you
talked about how you were raised in a
culture where you always had families
and I assume that you said in a culture
so most of your friends probably had
families as well that is so important um
if we're going to talk about how to fix
this problem it's not about dumping
money into schools it's not about
defunding the police it's not about
abolishing ice but across all
communities having more families like
the one that you seem to have been
raised with who did a great job with you
thank you make sure you have that
conversation with everyone because
that's something that is unifying and
hopefully everyone can be on board with
as opposed to divisive and burning down
buildings um cuz I think that's where it
starts where the change starts okay I
really do appreciate it Alana thank you
Alana air bump I appreciate it thank you
take care thanks Alana now remember if
you want these conversations to continue
please do consider joining up at lit.com
mugclub you get this wonderful hand
etched and painted mug tons of exclusive
content and it's what allows us to
continue to go out and make content like
this the kind of content that you can
never see on cable news by Design but
back to business next up is a gentleman
known as king
there we go can we do that all right
okay uh what's your name sir my name is
Kane Kane King King like like a royalty
like a royalty okay how do you spell it
k i n g okay see I didn't know if it
could go with a c you know it could
confuse me um so I don't know how for
well you know K sometimes C's make the C
it's okay I was trying to break that's
what we call a little breaking the eyes
didn't work um I don't know how familiar
you are if at all with uh changed my
mind segments um but kind of let me fill
you in a little bit on what it is that
we do that's okay you can knock just
don't steal it I asked someone tried to
do that once damn it I tried that's why
I came here is to steal the mic to steal
the mic I need a mic from my studio yo
all right well I wouldn't steal this one
it's pretty crappy all right no anything
work right now it's been upgraded since
I think uh our sound guy actually has
some really good mics I'll give give you
his home address his list of hobbies and
daily schedule I got you um so typically
what we do with change my mind is we we
we take uh topics that are often seen as
controversial you know in the media are
very very partisan bombastic and try and
sit down and hopefully have a rational
discussion where we rationalize our own
positions on controversial topics
obviously right now as you well know
here in Austin uh the black lives matter
riots have uh evolved it's been really
tough on this town I didn't know until I
came here I uh very much think that
black lives matter is a domestic Terror
organization if you disagree with me
you're more than welcome to change my
mind or if you have any questions well I
know I can't change your mind uh but
actually cuz you don't know
that if you're saying it's a domestic
terrorist uh organization yeah black the
black lives matter or organization
organization which is in charge of
obviously inspiring spurring these
protests the ones that team have a fubo
and stuff like that or I don't know
which companies they've teamed up with
but I take it specifically from their
website their Charter what they demand
what it is they're looking for um and of
course where the funding explain to me
why they are okay sure so here let me so
I don't know where you line up uh on I
think it's important to delineate here
between saying black lives matter which
I think everyone is on board with that's
what I'm about is say okay saying black
lives matter just like saying don't kick
puppies right it's like everyone says
okay that's great but then we do have to
get down to but what about dogs I don't
want to kick dogs either don't kick dogs
don't kick cats I don't kick cats you
see the point yeah uh I don't really get
what you're saying but my point is with
the black lives matter organization
right there is an organization there is
a charter there are official demands
that have been listed and they're going
about that with these protests that
evolve into riots that have cause $600
million in property damage uh anywhere
from 12 to 20 plus people who've been
killed at the riots 900 officer
casualties 14,000 arrests and these are
the demands from the black lives matter
organization that um you know I just not
only do I not agree with I think are
actually harmful to the black community
and using intimidation and the riots as
a matter of achieving them makes them in
my book uh domestic Terror organization
all right so let's talk so a domestic
terrorist organization so I just want to
make sure that there's not different
meanings for terrorism or anything like
that but you saying domest are you
saying their alignment with Isis and no
no no no no domestic means within the
United States okay so about the KKK
they're aligned with the KKK no they're
not aligned with the KKK but the KKK
could be a domestic Terror organization
domestic just means here in American so
do you agree that the KKK is a domestic
yes you do yes okay now since why do you
think that the KKK is a domestic
terrorist organization well obviously
they're not nearly as big in scope right
now is anti black lives matter but
anytime antifas a group yeah I don't
think they are well actually I have a
list right here of Demands from antifa
joint actions with black Liv matter for
example at Seattle and antifa's a
thought because if that's the case then
I'm anti-fascist hold on a second but
but black lives matter is a thought but
there's an organization black lives
matter that has an no black lives matter
is a phrase but there's also an
organization right same thing with
antifa you do have different cells and
they do have centralized demands uh with
which they unify with black lives matter
to me so let me say yeah KKK why would
they be a terrorist organization why
would Isis why would any of these types
of people so that would be that
terrorism is um using intimidation force
or violence in order to achieve an
ideological political end right and
that's what we see with black lives
matter just like the KKK so no I
appreciate your comparison no it's not a
compar I'm trying to understand so
before before because honestly I'm kind
of I'm changing up the segment right now
so what I'm doing right now is in you
can talk with me instead of me change
instead of me changing his mind I want
him to change my mind because think
about
the black lives matter organization is a
ter is a terrorist domestic or
organization group that is farfetched so
to be part of the mass and say that it's
not I want the person that has a
far-fetched thought to tell to uh to
convince me okay there's no convincing
on my part let me let me can I can I
pause you there can I ask you something
sure I think the idea of complete and
total police abolition and disrupting
the Western nuclear family is a radical
thought I think that's more far-fetched
then my response to
it I think it's more farfetched than my
response saying no don't completely
abolish the police to Black lives matter
I think it's more far-fetched than me
saying no we shouldn't completely
eliminate the nuclear American Family do
you believe in defunding APD I'm sorry
APD also police but uh funing place the
the issue is what black lives matter
demands so I want to start with that I
think that that is very farfetch and by
the way the majority of Americans
including black Americans do too so it's
not like I'm some minority the idea of
completely abolishing the police is a
radical idea say very radical yeah yeah
and it's going to be yeah so here's the
thing so do you support that oh yeah of
course I do completely abolishing the
police yeah of course why not abolishing
prisons trying to yeah I'm not too sure
on that I'm not going to answer your
question on that one but no that's their
demand I never said I was with black
lives matter oh okay all right well you
said it was a far-fetched position for
me to say it's a terror organization
yeah this Charter to me and the taxs use
it reads as a farfetch to use your term
Terror organization so it does matter
cuz I'm talking abolishing the police
okay complete abolition complete
abolition how did policing start in the
South do you know are we going to go
back to the slavery idea for slaves but
we're talking about complete abolition
of the police but would you think that
was a radical idea back in the day to
capture slaves to do stuff like that
don't you think that was kind of radical
I think slavery was a radical idea that
was a horrible idea and I'm really
grateful that we abolished it and I'm
really grateful that we don't have
slavery we don't have Jim Crow laws that
had the voting Civil Rights Act what I'm
talking about right now is complete
abolition of the police so what I'm
saying is though and that's this is why
I'm bringing it up the reason why we
have these extremes let's be honest
police are extreme that's an extreme
idea ex extreme ideologies right here
okay the reason why we have extremes
let's be honest as a black
person I'm not going to see the
abolition of police in my lifetime let's
let's just be honest this that has
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about hold on hold on so when we try to
ask for voting rights like back in the
day which should have been given when
the 13th Amendment got passed absolutely
but then it's kind of funny because
Malcolm X said
something he goes if we were equal there
wouldn't be any more additional laws to
be passed there wouldn't be there
wouldn't be no civil rights uh so so
when we so they're they're asking simple
they're asking simple things to be equal
to to get rid of segregation right um
well no black does matter wants more
segregation but continue I'm talking
back in the day I just I'm I'm tying up
with this right so um to ask all that
stuff like for the fact that we had to
ask after the 13 amendment after we said
equal we had to go and ask that makes
you
think that makes you think damn are we
really equal I was speaking to
Savannah and she's saying that we are
equal I said I'm
thinking are you duped or are you duping
me because how how can we be equal if we
needed extra if if if we needed a civil
rights move man so no no no no hold on a
second but I want no hold on because
you're jumping around you're not
answering my question but I will address
that one um in 20120 yeah I would
maintain whoever you were talking with I
don't Savannah you said I think so okay
yeah of course that we have equal rights
in 2020 and I don't see how abolishing
the police would uh in any way make
black Americans more equal to white
Americans considering it would harm them
most so I'm going to tell you a secret
that's in the black community right okay
tell me
King abolishing police ain't going to
happen still on The List of Demands it's
not going to happen well I have a
problem with it you know what I'm saying
and you want to know why cuz sh doesn't
go our way we have we have to say
completely abolish the police in order
to get them defunded so we make our
community safer that's what we have to
do that's what we have to say we have to
say completely abolish the police and
and and so when you said you supported
completely abolish the police that's
just a negotiating tactic no I really I
no no I really do believe whole heart
that we should abolish the police okay
yeah but first but that's not going to
happen let's be World there just so much
power why let me ask you this since
we're completely off the idea of it
being a terrorist organization the half
a billion dollars in property damage why
do you believe in abolishing the police
how would that help black Americans oh
there's a lot of things you can start
investing in different or organizations
in mental health uh establish another
establish another department there's a
lot of things to be honest I don't have
to answer that CU let me tell you why
well you do if you're sending out a
far-fetched idea to use your theory here
that's a radical uh idea right yeah it's
a r radical farfetch idea Poli how would
you replace it no just how slavery is a
radical idea right here's what I'm
saying as me as a American I'm saying
why not it let's just abolish the police
let's just see what happens if it
crashes and burns okay then it crashes
bur that's how black lives matter if it
crashes and burns but many black people
be killed innocent black people do you
really think so yeah far more black
people will be killed if you abolish the
police but we're not being killed right
now by the police what's the number one
uh uh cause of death for young black
Americans can you tell me that I'm not
sure is it
diabetes no what is it it's homicide
it's not even close yeah homicide yeah
homicide black on black crime black comp
black crime it's not even close if we're
talking about and by the way if we're
talking about black lives matter and
that is the number one cause of death
with young black Americans and the vast
majority of black Americans don't want
to abolish the police you were talking
about the vast majority of Americans
black Americans don't want to abolish
the police where you getting out from
infow Wars where you getting that from
no I'm not getting from infow Wars but
we can bring the statistics out here
also bring you do doubt the idea that
homicide is the number one cause of
death for young black Americans I'm not
doubting anything no not that um so by
well let's just let's just if if don't
agree with what I say then maybe just
tell me why cuz that way we can both
rationalize our position rather than
just saying well I don't trust you um
it's the number one cause of death and
if you take away the police right and
you abolish prisons which is on this
List of Demands as well and if you
deconstruct the idea of the nuclear
family which is again a list that's the
most difficult that's the worst to me
when you look at black lives man in
their demands you will harm black
Americans the most because they're not
being often record numbers by cops there
as a matter of fact black Americans are
not killed more than white Americans by
cops they're killed less but they are
killed by other fellow black Americans
in record numbers you're talking about
37 times the national homicide rate from
a Barack Obama Bureau of Justice study
you're talking about 10 times the rate
of committing violent crime in other
Americans right now and I don't think
that's because or would be improved by
defunding or abolishing the police okay
so how would it help young black
Americans I was waiting for you to
finish cuz everything you're saying I
don't agree with so um so what's the
number one killer of young black
Americans no it could be homicide that's
fine so you disagree here here here's no
everything you said after that and
trying to try to justify that I don't so
let's say this okay so how about you
rationalize your position how would
abolishing the police help with the
number one cause of death young black
Americans being homicide do you believe
that the police
brutalize and kill black people
disproportionately compared to white
people statistically that's not a
reality no disproportionately nope no do
you have those statistics can we see
those I do I feel I feel like Trump when
you had that interview with um that dude
uh on Fox he said he's all right bring
the statis he's like bring the stats
yeah so how many unarmed black men were
killed by police last year I don't know
nine how many white guys I don't know 19
what percentage of America do black
people make up last time I checked it
was like 13% about 13% 12 13% what
percentage of homicides no I'm not
talking about homicide 53 what
percentage of robberies I'm not talking
about homicide hold on wait hold on I'm
not talking let's just talk about the
police no this is no I'm getting to the
police what percentage of people were
black who were killed by police I want
to say this real quickly 25% if
okay so what you're saying is if we get
rid of the police black people will get
harmed in that at at the end but we're
already particularly black women and
children okay but we're already getting
murdered by each other so what what are
the police doing to solve that yeah so
that so so that's so that's what I'm
saying that's what I'm trying to get at
so let's get back let's get back to this
well they do put them in jail they do
arrest people and if you remove those
consequences you think there would be
less crime in the United States no
there's no from Young blackes you think
the homicide rate would go down what
you're bringing up to me right now is
another conversation that I need to have
in the black community that hey there's
some homicide going on that we need to
fix because we have some internal
problems that were brought on to us
because of this country how do we fix it
so let's be productive how do we fix the
I want to talk about what I want to talk
about you brought these out and I want
to see these yeah but um but what I'm
what I'm trying to say is
that policing have they ever prevented a
murder a black and black crime murder or
black on black murder I would imagine so
yeah or or you just saying we can arrest
them
yeah you know I wouldn't have the stats
on exactly how many black murders have
been stopped by police officers but you
could certainly cross reference the
amount of calls to the police for let's
say an armed robbery or a violent
assault that was stopped by police
officers I would imagine it's in the
thousands okay was that reasonable I
don't know the stats would that be
reasonable I was I was I was gen honest
so no no but I'm saying is that a
reasonable answer like I don't have the
exact number but you would probably
cross reference how many 911 calls of a
violent crime in action and how many
times the police have stopped or saved
people sure that's yeah that's so I
don't have the number but it would be
significant sure so just like with white
people do you agree so let's Okay so I
want to talk about police real quick
then I want to get back to uh the
terrorist because that's I know that's
what you're here for to and I'm sorry I
I do apologize but no no I appreciate
you sitting down and being respectful do
you believe I like your tattoo too oh
yeah Kan yeah the Kanye yeah the Kanye
tattoo do you regret that now with him
being a little oh no okay good
absolutely not yeah you don't have to
agree with someone 100% to like exactly
yeah um so
uh I forgot my question let me let me
get it uh it was about do you believe
that the police should have more
accountability yes yeah I have a big
problem so I've talked about this with
police unions just like I have a problem
with teachers unions um I do believe
that there does need to be some police
reform and I do believe that it needs to
be easier to um expel bad police
officers how do we do that I think there
are a couple of things that we can do
that should be some common ground
approaches and that's why I have such a
problem with the black lives matter
organization because the Common Ground
approaches that we could start with for
example getting dissolving police unions
or at least lessening their control to a
degree or at least even changing the
card check rules that we have um I think
that we could have more accountability I
don't think we should I don't think that
we should do away entirely with um with
the immunity of police officers but I do
think that we need higher accountability
and an ability to get rid of police
officers to have a centralized database
so that police officers who've committed
infractions can't just move from County
to County these are things that we can
start with
unfortunately these are the kinds of
suggestions that have been shouted down
by black lives matters Founders and
activists as racist so here's the thing
do okay this just it those reasonable I
mean I'm not saying no changes yeah yeah
no sure are but I have a question it's
just say yes or no do you believe you
have a
privilege well I have a mom and a dad
and I think and I was raised in a family
who love me I think that's a huge
privilege White Privilege why do you
assume that that's white privilege
having a mom and a dad no I'm asking I
said Do you believe you have white
privilege I don't know what that means
okay so here's what you can do instead
of I think uh to be honest with you
debating with people about changing your
mind don't do this don't walk out on
this man cuz this is not going to be a
good way to go when an argument you go
to the White Privilege card hold on wait
hold not a good I'm about to explain no
I don't care about here's the thing let
me tell you something real quick instead
of doing that talk to your people about
what you just told me mhm and continue
that continue that message Continue hey
I don't care I'm like you can say hey
look black lives matter I don't agree
with y'all but here's the thing we can
have more account everything you told me
is gold and I believe we hit all angles
of oppressing black people if you hit
the you come on my side and say yeah
they do need more accountability we can
start getting things down but if we see
nobody not doing anything we have to say
abolish the police for in order for you
to speak up and say something like that
it's that radical like no abolish the
police no no no but here is because
let's be honest well no that's but
that's listen that that may be the way
that you feel and I appreciate that and
I appreciate it as a negotiating tactic
or whatever you believe but when you
have the mayor of Minneapolis saying I
support defunding the police and lays
out a list and they go no complete
abolition of the police Poli shout him
down and shame him out yeah that's not
helpful that's not productive now I do
have these conversations with my people
I do have a conversation with millions
of people every month where I've talked
about these ideas and I'm having a
conversation with you right now
unfortunately I see black lives matter
and black leadership not having
conversations about what would truly
help the lives of people in the black
community no there is and as a matter of
fact the idea of disrupting and
deconstructing the Western nuclear
family would do a reparable harm to the
black community so quick yeah yeah sure
you can take this I can take so I want
to learn more about so this is one yeah
this is one thing that I think is really
important so because unfortunately you
do have you do have racists out there
I'm not dis acknowledging racists and I
think you have racist across the board
um when I look at the numbers for
example at 10 times the violent crime
rate from Black Americans or I look at
37 times likely to commit homicide that
it's the number one kill of black
Americans I don't pull a Nick Cannon and
look at it and think it's because of
race you where he said melanin is what
gives a soul I look at it and I say okay
this is the reality statistically why is
that the case and it's obviously not
because you have more melon in your skin
because I'm white I don't I don't
believe that makes anyone more
inherently violent but it does cross
reference with a problem that we have in
the black community that black
leadership is not addressing with 70%
raised in fatherless households if you
don't have a mom and a dad you are much
more likely to commit violent crime if
you're in a community without how how do
they have how come why is the reason
that they don't have mom and dads why do
you think that well a big part of it is
a war in poverty and centralized
government and incentives to actually
you've heard the term baby mama that
actually comes from Lindon Johnson and
model cities and the idea that you
actually get more money from the
government should we invest money into
communities instead of gingification
well hold on a second what do you mean
should we invest more money yeah and and
and you know how much we spend on the
Warren poverty over 20 trillion $23
trillion so what's the number what more
should we spend on communities uh
government housing EBT food stamps
social safety nets if 23 trillion hasn't
improved it it's actually made crime
worse what should we do I because here's
the thing I don't agreee with all the
food stamps and all that stuff and and
everything like that right okay but
don't you believe that we shouldn't on
those sides of towns schools integrating
schools again cuz right now schools are
not to segade let's be honest well black
lives matter want segregated schools and
hospitals and I'm about to get to that
so I want to I want to get to that but
really quick and there's a reason why um
so really quick what I want to say is
this cuz I would agree with you the idea
that we I don't want segregation by
Design or policy I think it's a bad
thing let me tell you something there's
a lot of emotion in this movement
there's a reason why that in Minneapolis
the mayor got booed right there's a lot
of emotion and we're not gonna say every
move we make is right we're gonna do
some things that are wrong there's
points where we should have listen we're
not listen because there's a lot of
emotion and we're tired and we're scared
right so that's one
thing that is very Justified because we
don't know if we can trust our
politicians anymore I'm over here
fighting city council right now to get
this $100 million budget and then
there's some things that say yes we
promis to do that we're going to look
into that next thing now I'm hearing
other talks so there's a lot I'll say
that's not a black black thing I
wouldn't trust politicians any further
than I can throw them with my bad knee
ad that's not very far so but as as a
black person I I I there there's really
much I can't trust him so one thing that
we want to talk about segregation right
that the uh black lives matter they they
want to do second they want to second
grade right essentially a lot of it yeah
a lot of it yeah I mean you've seen that
right you've seen those calls I I I need
to I need to do more research on that
but one thing I want to say is this uh
and I think they're probably fallowing
the basis of Malcolm
X says the reason why that we need to
separate because these segregation
wasn't even real in the first place if
they don't want us in there they're
going to oppress us so what is the point
of trying to integrate if it's going to
harm us we have to segregate we have to
start doing our own thing and I believe
that's why there is a there's a there's
a um an idea of sorry segregation um and
to be honest with you as me as king I
can see see one side or the other I
believe did you mean as king an
individual or as as a king no no King no
king king's another you must get that it
gets confusing it does get confusing I
like that that's what I like to do okay
I like it um but another thing I want to
say is this but can I can I um explain
to you something too do you understand
too is my my concern with that is first
off yeah I think we need to address when
we say black lives matter and people get
upset if you say well why AR we talking
about all black lives when the number
one cause of death H we do say all black
lives yeah I do I I leave I leave the
protest we do say all lives well I don't
see these protests addressing the issue
of homicide in Black communities I see
them going after defunding or abolishing
the police which doesn't even show up on
the list do well it's not in the black
Liv's matter Charter um protest we do
further up there is well the charter is
dismantle cisgender privilege uplift no
no this is from the website I know
saying and then it was reiterated from
black Liv matter one of the founders
there in the New York Times so these
aren't Fringe views this is where I go
directly to the source
right I think that if we're talking
about a minuscule amount and a dishonest
statistic that black people are more
targeted or killed at a higher level
than white people in this country no
they're not yeah they are they're not
they make up a if you look at police
interactions meeting for violent crimes
black people are actually killed less
often unarmed black people than unarmed
white people and if you look at the
percentage of crimes that are made up
and again I'm not saying that's because
of black I'm saying it is a problem that
needs to be addressed and you're not
addressing it by saying it's a police's
fault I think you need to be addressing
it by saying we need more fathers in the
household instead of saying deconstruct
and destroy the central nuclear family
that's the greatest privilege I've ever
had in my life as a father and a mom in
the house I just I just want to ask this
real quick have you ever seen the
documentary 13 13 yeah I don't know if I
have no yeah do you have Netflix I do I
have Netflix I PID for it and I me me
and my my girlfriend we we watched it
last night and it's something i' highly
recommend that you watch it because 13
yeah I saw 13 Ghosts that movie sucked
yeah I pretty sure Terrible No but uh I
want to say this you I think what you're
talking about from your so I said
convince me right mhm so um although
it's changed my mind but yeah yeah or CH
change my mind whatever it's a beautiful
seg by but uh no I I I can't I can't if
if if KKK is considered a domestic uh
terrorist organization I'm I'm not going
to say that do you call these riots or
protests these are protests so let me
ask you this $600 million in property
damage you're talking about dozens of
deaths you're talking about 14,000
arrests 900 officer casualties uh what
would be required for you to consider a
riot
let me tell you why it's on a
riot and it's simply because of this and
it's white people in property right why
are we bringing up SI why did you f and
this is just the way that we think and
it's uh well black people's property
it's no it's inherently it's black
people's property it's inherently
instilled though disproportionately
black people's property why is that a
concern why did you say that first and
then lies
later well it was the biggest number I
went through the whole thing it's not
that I list it as a priority I can
restate uh for to 22 people dead
depending on which number you use 900
officer casualties I figured I wouldn't
lead with officer casualties because you
believe in abolishing the police
entirely so I figured addressing the
fact that disproportionately black
property has been damaged in the black
community maybe was something you would
care about more but I guess black
property doesn't matter either so what
about David
Dorne you know who that is yeah I've
heard of him I think again my friend
second that's important yeah um do you
think role models in any Community are
important cuz David Dorne was a police
officer a black police officer who
served in St Louis who served in
Missouri his whole life and he was
responding to another fellow black
business owner's shop being looted and
burned in what you call a protest I call
a riot and he was shot for a westing
house for a television set so I'll tell
you I'll tell you this black man when we
when we does that matter when we take
when I take care of my agenda of black
lives matter and all that stuff that I'm
doing I'll be more than happy to address
David D Dorne right David Dorne right d
yeah but right now he's not my he's not
at the top of my priority why does his
life not matter it's not about life it's
not matter why does a a black man who
did nothing wrong never committed a
crime never had a a rap sheet a man who
served his community who served black
people in his community who did a lot of
good work with his wife in the community
to bridge the racial divide why does
that man bleeding out in the street shot
dead over a TV not
matter seems to me that would be a life
that matters most cuz it's innocent
because there's been a lot of innocent
black lives that got uh that got taken
away you said this isn't a priority why
cuz this is an example of why it's the
number one homicide rate in the black
community a man was shot over a
television set a good man why doesn't
that bother you there's a lot of people
that get shot down no it does bother me
it really does here's the thing what
happens it really does bother me but
only got so much energy in the day you
know what I'm saying hey if we want to
go ahead and protest about David Dorne
let's do it I'm about that right we be
focusing on what actually affects black
lives which is we can go ahead and focus
on that right black on black crie but if
I'm going to go ahead and protest about
that the people that are bringing up DAV
and Dorne I want you on my side saying
black lives matter well I'm on your side
saying that sh Derk do we say Shin in
the United States Dereck Shin I think
that that guy should be charged but do
you understand what I'm saying do you
understand so we were here's no no
here's the point everyone no no this
does matter because everyone white black
listen to me everyone yeah I know but
you were you asked me a question
everyone black white yellow red was on
board and this is what concerns me we
all saw that tape of George Floyd and
thought that it was horrific okay we all
agreed with it
unfortunately Minds have been turned
against the cause of not just black
lives matter of the organization but
right now this black movement because of
the crime the death and then David it's
not going to be perfect as no yeah but
it's not going to be perfect hey hey
America fought in war and done some fued
up stuff but we fought for the right
reasons right so are you saying black
Liv matters at war with the United
States then it is a terrorist
organization let me tell you this real
quick is black Liv matter at war with
the United States no it's not so here's
here's here's I want to say though okay
the reason why I'm speaking on David
Dorne like that because there's certain
sides right and right now now we're
having I think a debate or something
like that no we're not having a debate
you know a conversation and it's about
changing our minds or something like
that or changing your mind essentially
and I feel like that you're bringing up
David
Dorne to push down and I'm saying feel
so let's talk on motion to no I
appreciate that yeah you know what I'm
saying to neglect yeah I felt that
earlier it better not be hobo piss yeah
no no no we're good no no um it's it's I
or any piss all right yeah hashtag we
don't judge any piss no piss at all all
right no but it's just that hobo piss is
not uh I mean it hasn't been
tested you don't know where that's you
don't know where the hobo piss is coming
from it's okay we don't need to be that
politically correct we both would prefer
nonh we
agree no Honestly though I feel like
that you are neglecting my com our
conversation and and trying to point The
View somewhere else and that's why I'm
like
this and that's why I'm like we can put
Dave and Dorne at another sign but come
out with me come and protest come come
join my work um I'm sorry my study group
groups that I do for white allly shits
my organization come get involved show
me that I matter show no hold on a
second I don't agree with abolishing the
police so I won't come out and March
with you I don't agree with these Dems
so I won't come out and March with you
but we do agree on some things like
defunding the police no I don't agree
with what's going on with these protests
and the violence do you know some people
on the protest don't believe in
abolishment I know some people don't but
the black lives matter organization does
so in other words if there's some good
members of Isis who don't believe in
killing infidels that's fine but I'm
still not going to sign up with Isis I
have a fundamental problem with black
man of the organization so my point is
this this is how I'm showing that I care
having a conversation I'm not going to
link arms with anyone associated with
the black last M organization nobody's
I'm not I'm not I'm not mhed Ali son I'm
not linking our supp with MLK Ben Carson
I'm not but but I'm not I'm not Ben
Carson but I'm not I'm not associated
with the I'm not associated with the
black lives matter movement oh I'm sorry
with the U I'm sorry not mov I apologize
uh the
organization and we both agree on the
funding so if they see somebody like you
uh louder I believe or something like
that man that is like wow you're going
to change people's minds yo you have
that you can change people Minds yo and
say yo you march with that person about
defending the police and then I go with
you and I do DAV D It's All About a
collaboration I love in I'm trying to
change people's minds to have more dads
and you work for an organization that
wants less dads I don't work for them
you're associated with an organization
that fundamentally seeks to destroy
associated with them do you said you
said black lives matter yeah black lives
matter yeah that's the organization
that's the founding organization speak
black lives matter doesn't matter I also
and by the way I did have uh I I was
associated with the no hold a second
because agree that I don't I don't I
don't I don't associate black lives
matter but if there's black lives matter
the label there I'll have nothing to do
with it because of this in their Charter
and because of the funding and where it
goes to I can't now if you said I'm King
this is my Charter and we both sat down
we both agreed and we said okay these
are fundamental issues on which we can
agree we can find some common ground I
would march with you but not if it's
abolition of the police so why are you
dictating how I can serve and change
people's minds
if it only agrees inherently with your
platform no we both agree we can have a
protest about David Dorne about um
having accountability for the police
what I'm trying to show is right now you
do have some um some people that follow
you yes that are you know that are on
one side of the spectrum and let's be
honest you come on no uh that
that uh that really don't believe that
black lives don't matter that really
don't believe all that stuff that really
don't that really sees me and and I
disagree I disagree here's I think no no
no no no no I think this is the problem
I am telling you that I don't agree with
black Liv go ahead and finish yeah so if
they see you sorry see you coming
out and doing that with this I don't I
with this person that's not a liberal or
a conservative whatever but a radical
coming out with me and saying yeah we do
agree with um you know accountability
with the police we do understand that
David dor was a tragedy we do understand
that George Floyd was messed up man that
is freaking dope that's going to change
the whole game but until then I don't
have I don't have your back you know
what I'm saying why didn't you come out
with a tea party I'm sorry why didn't
you come out with a tea party because I
don't know much about the Tea Party
that's the issue there right so we had a
platform of less government intervention
of less taxation of less uh less of a
deficit that we've been seeing a growing
national debt there were plenty of black
Americans there my point is a lot of
people didn't show up because they
didn't agree they didn't support
limbered government candidates that
being said do you know what the main
difference was between the tea party
which was every bit as big every bit as
many people members and protesters uh
from that and the black lives matter
protests was that a question yeah what
was what do you think the biggest
difference is and why I would be okay
speaking at a tea party rally and not
okay showing up at a black lives matter
Associated rally we already you already
explained why you're not showing dozens
dead hundreds of officers casualties 600
million but that's I can't have anything
to do with it you understand and that's
that's the point of view that doesn't
matter the point of view if you actually
want to change the perception of black
lives matter why aren't you speaking out
against the riots why would you call
them protests when you know that they're
riots you just acknowledge the crime in
the property honest with you right I'm
going to be honest with you cuz right
now they're not a threat to me they're
not a threat to my family sure they are
but no they're not they absolutely are
let me let me finish the police I have
nightmares of my brother getting shot by
the police I have nightmares of my
sister getting shot by the police I
don't have nightmares of RI riers or
protesters doing anything to my brother
and sister so if we go based off emotion
I don't care if you call it a right or a
protest I'm woring about getting police
be held accountable and uh eventually uh
abolishing them that's why you have
that's why I'm not I don't say I don't a
a riot or a protest if I see something
burn down on fire is my brother and
sister up there nope black lives you
know what I'm saying so and I'm being
honest and that's what it's a white
white brother and sister a white brother
and what do you mean well our Bo we
can't we don't consider them brothers
and sisters no no I'm no I meant
literally my brother and my sister like
my family okay okay yeah yeah you know
what I'm saying like no sorry no not
like that if anybody's in that yeah no
but I'm saying I'm like my family when I
say my brother I am I do get I get I
can't sleep at night I get nightmares of
the police can I can I say something or
are you continuing I just I I appreciate
what you go ahead yeah yeah I just I
just want to emphasize on that that it's
something you know what I'm saying from
I appreciate that I really do appreciate
that and I think that's where we have a
fun I think that's where we have a
fundamental disagreement I think we
agree on some things which I think has
been productive and I think we for
example what you just said this is
emotionally right I think that you are
coming from a place of emotion and this
is all emotion but and I coming from a
place of facts and statistics now you
may be feel more afraid of police
officers but the reality is you are far
more likely to be killed harmed by
someone in your community in these
protests right now not a police officer
that's a statistical reality just like I
have nightmares about spiders it's very
unlikely that I die from a black widow
it's far more likely that I die from a
home invasion but I have nightmares
about spiders because they're Pricks and
I don't like them and they scare me but
that's an emotion but here's the thing
you don't know what my risk is cu you
you haven't been in my community and so
that's one thing and secondly I haven't
told anybody about this because it's a
I'm sad and I'm ashamed of of the
situation but you want to know why I'm
afraid of cops because one night I was
in my car I did not drive I did not do
anything and I was drinking and my car
wasn't able to move so I literally got
in my car waiting for Uber to come right
after night of drinking the cops came by
and they said hey how are you doing
I was scared out of my mind and when
they asked if I drink I said yes I'm
waiting for Uber to come through they
end up charging me with the DWI and I
had to fight that right now yeah well
it's illegal yeah you see what I'm
saying so what I'm trying to say is this
but that's not because you're black open
alcohol container did they test you they
breathe you yeah they breiz me the DWI
is higher than you must have been pretty
hammered yeah but the thing is that I
wasn't driving and I told him I wasn't
driving doesn't matter no it does I did
speak to L about it and it's being it's
being fixed right now but do you know
much money that's costing me do You Know
Much anguish that's causing me I was
talking to it changed my whole life I
got depressed because of it and I can't
help but to look and
say damn what if I was white I'm not
saying it doesn't happen to white people
it does I have white people they go yeah
I went through that too but as a as a
person of a as a as a the mind of a
black man it's always going to be in my
head now you were in your neighborhood
when this happened I was like on yeah
like on on the side town uh on Riverside
where I was staying at okay and this is
the big issue too that I have with black
lives matter and these these
organizations right now in the charter
is that if you look at the the riots
they infringe on other people's rights
right no so here's the con this is what
I believe the fundamental role of the
police should be I don't believe that
non-violent drug offenders in their own
house should be jailed I think we can
agree on that I think you should be able
to do whatever you want not have a
felony
right right of course yeah yeah and and
Donald Trump has actually done more for
non-violent drug offenders than any
president really in modern history he
let several people go let me let me hold
on let me finish come on you do this lot
and say let you finish you got let meish
that you do it a lot but um and I
understand with King you're used to
dismissing people no don't
do um a police officer's job should be
should be to protect the rights of uh
its citizens without infringing on
rights on privacy rights on property
rights right that's why we have a
constitution now you drinking in your
house I have a big problem with that but
a police officer when you are drinking
to the level of a DWI which let's be
honest is up there in a car it is his
duty to make sure that you don't run
over a child hit somebody else's kid
harm someone else in your community the
moment you get in that car and I
understand you say that you weren't
driving but that's the most common
excuse that's used that's why it's the
law you cannot have an alcohol
percentage and be at the wheel that you
have an open alcohol container in your
car so was just a breath Riser test and
know and but you understand that that
that police officer is doing it because
you're black that police officer is
doing it because they don't want you
hitting someone else's kid and speaking
of someone who had a close friend who
was hit by a deep someone who was drunk
and will never walk properly again yeah
I full-heartedly support the police
officer right why I didn't dve CU I have
a friend that's exactly that same thing
I actually lost a few people you know
what I'm saying but I was honest and I
was straight up forward and my key and
the thing my key wasn't man you broke
the law no it wasn't though so that's
why I have people fighting it it's going
to get overturned hopefully you win
thank you I appreciate hopefully you win
if it's not a law yeah yeah yeah yeah um
so but that's that's what I'm saying it
was wrong in that situation and I can't
help but look to say down black but but
um here what I want to
say I hope one
day that you come join me that you do
come and scope it out you do come you
know and do all that you get your
followers and say hey look this is
what's this is what's up mhm you know
what I'm
saying call it a riot and I'll do it say
that the property damage the deaths the
900 officer casualties condemn it say
that these riots have to stop and we
have to turn to Peaceful Pro protest
like MLK Jr advocated and I'll show up
with you you'll show up my protest if I
say that yeah but if you actually do it
and speak about that at your protest and
go out and speak out against these
current riots because you said here that
you didn't consider it a riot and I
still ask you that question you haven't
answered it if not 20 people dead 900
officer casualties 14,000 arrests $600
million in property damage see I reverse
the order because I know you don't like
the property thing if that doesn't
constitute a riot what is required to
constitute rights I'm saying you've
walked down Sixth Street man it's
nothing it's nothing but homeless people
in
wooden boards business have been destroy
yeah we got to no it's been wooden
boards because of um because of Co 19 no
it's not wooden boards because of Co 19
yes it is yes it is yes yes it is wood
is wood is
permeable you wouldn't use wood to block
germs you seen mold grow on wood no they
put wood up there because it was shut
down no that's not why it shut down
that's not why it shut down it's not why
it was shut down in deep elen when you
can look underneath those wooden
boards I I went down to deep these
businesses have had their Windows broken
and you just said that you saw people
burning cars here you just said that you
saw people committing crimes people can
rewind the tape you said you saw some
out here and then you said it
wasn't a riot I'm sorry I meant to say
that I seen that on T I meant to say I
seen that on TV I'm sorry okay yeah I
yeah yeah no there there are rights that
are out there yes you know what I'm
saying they are I'm not going to lie I'm
not going to it's a rius movement right
now it's a protest movement that has
some that guess has a couple of bad
apples come on come on $600 million in
property damage you're talking about
dozens dead 900 officer casualties
that's not a cubat apples man in every
major city across the country it didn't
happen with the tea party that didn't
happen with people like MLK it's
unprecedented it's people looking for an
excuse to commit crimes and I won't go
out with people who do so who fly the
black lives matter flag whether you
agree with their Charter or not because
that is the reason for these riots and I
think what's most important is
addressing the real problem right now
which is crime in the communities
largely due to Broken families without
fathers and I want you have a mom and a
dad no they passed away I'm sorry were
you raised with a mom and a dad yeah do
you consider that a
privilege sure do you have a lot of
friends who maybe don't have fathers 70%
of black households don't have father I
don't have a lot of friends okay but no
I want to I want to say You Can Count Me
among your friends now I think you're I
think you're a decent guy yeah likewise
um no I just I just I just wanted to say
this
though um and I was speaking on uh the
protest you said back at
MLK that there is peaceful protest sorry
Mar Lu King there was peaceful protest
stuff like that right M okay Junior to
clarify not the guy who you know nailed
notes but what
El but what was that from 2020 oh okay
whatever didn't black people get abused
by the police and other white people at
those protests there's footage of that
that did happen so so if did happen at
some protests and there were also some
protests where white people marched with
them yeah oh yeah we know that but
wouldn't you call that a
riot I would call it a gross abuse of
power and crimes yeah that's not a RI
like white people killing killing
lynching uh white people lynching black
people I would just say that's a
lynching that's a that's a crime that
should be prosecuted and I support the
death penalty for people who Lynch so if
you attack and let me make sure if you
attack but I'm talking about the MLK
movement wasn't right
no people people did get Lynch because
of the mar luuk King Jr movement so if
people are getting lynched constantly
because it's civil rights his movement
was a response to lynching rightfully so
and you're not going I'm not defending
lynching at alln horribly I want to be
clear about that isn't that a riot if it
consistently happens if it was a ritual
because when people go out and protest
and burn something down that in a sense
is a ritual ritualistic way of saying
hey look give us attention so isn't that
a riot so they're both bad why are we
arguing lynching is bad riots are bad if
you consider I'm against riots and I'm
against lynching okay if you consider
those times back in the day a riot where
white people did really messed up
stuff sure I'll call this a riot yeah
now that being said you weren't having
this happening in Mass numbers in cities
with the kind of damage and lives loss
as you are now but I think lynching is
terrible and riots are terrible they
like 10,000 black people died during l m
at the MLK protest talking about history
if you're talking about lynching
throughout the entirety of the United
States I don't know what that number is
I'm sure it's terrible if you talking
about how many people were enslaved it's
not really fair to draw that comparison
to four months but what I'm saying is to
four months yeah yeah but maybe any
modern movement that has been this RI
nothing's even close but we do have to
wrap it up yeah okay but lynching though
lynching there's a high number of
lynchings that happened more than uh how
many people you said died right now yeah
uh it depends which number you use
anywhere from 18 to 20 some we'll do
it's way more than 20 something no I'm
talking about right now but I'm talking
about the lynching back oh I don't have
the number of Lynch it was way more you
ever talking about throughout the
history of America I would I'm talk the
Civil Rights I'm talking with the ml the
mar king I don't have the number yeah
it's way more I wish I I I would say
it's about 200 right um is that a right
well there's a difference between a
lynching which is you know for example
there's a difference between an
assassination which is is wrong and
burning down and here's the difference
lynching is hateful directed towards one
person right these riots are harming
black communities that's a big problem
too this is the first time it's
unprecedent where you have black people
burning down and looting black
businesses and shooting black police
officers and that's again what tells me
it's disingenuous and it's not about
racial equality it's about using an
excuse to commit crime and I won't show
up for a movement that doesn't outright
condemn especially when it's not
addressing the real problem I think all
black lives matter and I think when you
to address the number one cause of death
in the black community and it's not
police officers so police accountability
sure yeah I know this guy's yelling I
think he's just a crazy person police
accountability sure but the root cause
of this problem is we need more families
and black lives matter seeks to
completely deconstruct and disrupt it I
think this is more harmful if you add up
the charter and we'll have this here you
can take this with you I want to take
this but if you have it let me just
finish it this way and then I'll let you
have uh we we'll finish this out you can
say one more thing all right if you
abolish the police completely abolish
the police you completely abolish
prisons and you seek to disrupt the
Western prescribed nuclear family
structure you will irreparably harm the
black community far more than any police
officer ever could okay so I want to say
this though uh I appreciate talking
talking you about this I wish that we
can March together to be honest with you
but I can't say there's a lot of things
I disagree with you on I know and that's
them I disagree with you on too but if
but we do we do both agree that uh
police need to be held accountable yeah
and more accountability I also how about
this another one police unions gone how
about teachers unions gone I don't know
much about teachers I don't like to
speak on anything I don't know about
well the reason I okay this is a totally
different topic but here's the issue
it's very consistent for me to be
against the police unions why I am a
conservative I'm one of those right-
Wingers I have a problem with unions
because they remove accountability
across the board so you may not know
this but the average per pupil funding
for example in inner city areas like
Detroit DC Chicago significantly higher
than even a lot of white wealthy
Suburban areas it doesn't go to the
students the education system isn't
getting better it's not a money problem
so we have a union problem there as well
so I would I think we could find some
common ground there if we had some extra
time to sit down and talk about how
unions and government projects and no
bid contracts hurt the country at large
but specifically yeah the black
community you talking about teachers in
oh I'm talking about all different kinds
of unions and I'm talking about the war
on poverty and the corruption that
happens there it's often done so under
the guise of helping black Americans and
it often harms them and that's something
that I do talk about because I do want
better have a conversation with you on
that honestly yeah maybe we'll have you
back on the show sometime if you would
do maybe by Skype yeah yeah all right
thank you King I appreciate it man we'll
get your info yeah cool cool thanks
brother I really appreciate it yeah of
course I appreciate you thank you King
everybody that was really
nice well see that wasn't so bad and we
could have had more conversations like
that if antifa didn't show up
and try to shut the whole thing down and
we'll have more on that in next week's
installment but here's a little
taste you like to come over and talk
this narrative is dangerous and this
narrative got Garr Foster murder let's
change a sign let's change a sign we're
going to change a sign just for
you two years ago after numerous
conversations with my husband who was on
the off one second stop silencing black
voices stop silencing black voices stop
silencing black voices stop silencing
black voices
on
we